hi Internet I'm back and I have a story
for you I guess it's a story it's also a
series of thoughts strung together based
on stories that have happened to my real
life instead of my fake life these are
really stories because a story seems to
have a beginning middle and end these
are just situations I guess which all
fit lovely into the story of my life
shine I realized lately that I have a
lot of social anxiety and it comes into
play especially um with strangers and
with strangers who are asking me
something
for instance in New York or Brooklyn
rather where I live please don't come
hurt me physically okay I just could not
deal with that in Brooklyn on the
streets there's a lot of times people
young young fresh-faced
go-getters that care about the world and
causes and issues and things like that
so they will stand on the street with a
clipboard and they will solicit people
walking by to see if they want to sign
up or donate money or time for their
cause and I hate when I have to walk by
one because sidewalks aren't so big and
you can see them from afar away and it's
not that you can just cross the street
you go to the other side and be fine no
you're not safe because they're on the
other side also and headphones don't
work because they will solicit you even
if you have headphones on and I haven't
figured out the right and appropriate
dialogue to say to be nice and also
dismissive you know like Oh No thank you
it thinks anyway but no I already donate
time online to your costs I can never
make a decision in
moment of what to say for instance I'm
walking on the street today and I see a
girl with a clipboard from a distance
and my brain starts going oh God thank
you but no thank you
no silent little I couldn't figure out
what to do and so she says tease me do
you have a second to talk about cleaner
water and I just went as I'm walking a
combination of every possible word
phrase thing in my brain and it just
came out in a letters and sound vomit of
no so I think I should work to my
benefit because I think she might have
thought I had medical issues and so it's
better for both of us that we don't talk
about cleaner water though I do actually
I care about cleaner water it's why I
buy a Brita filter I should've just said
that I have a Brita filter thank you why
did it always happens after the fact
thanks for listening YouTube I salute
you